wenn sie sich jetzt fragen ich glaube an
wenn sie sich jetzt fragen was der gut
aussehende sympathische schlagfertige
mittel junge mann aus der schweiz findet
asse mitgebracht hat man kann ihnen
sagen das hat was mit joe biden zu tun
dem amerikanischen präsidenten und er
mag ihn nicht besonders liebt konnte
vielmals für diesen stein gesetzt ich
meine ich wusste mir zu überlegen was
bringst du für ein thema weil in dieser
bisherigen sendezeit habe ich jetzt die
bayern gegen mich aufgebracht ich habe
die frauen gegen sich aufgebracht ich
habe eine komödie die bundesliga haben
einfach keine freude wo sie gegen etwas
sagen dann in einen neuen verein finden
sehen wir uns verständigen können und
mein ärgernis heute
joe biden und diese amerikanische
präsident entschuldigung das ist jetzt
eine lehnstuhl diagnose ist von einer
unfassbaren
inkompetenz was die amerikaner also ich
wünschte mir annegret kramp karrenbauer
ins weiße haus hier hätte das besser
organisiert als die amerikaner wie er
diesen abzug in afghanistan noch das ist
unglaublich die sind einfach davon
gerannt gute bekommt vielleicht nach dem
friedensnobelpreis dafür weil obama
hatte den friedensnobelpreis bekommen
bei der nord afrika bombardiert hat und
bekommt den der andere fürs davonrennen
er hat gigantische mengen von
kriegsmaterial zurückgelassen er hat
tausende von menschen im land sitzen
lassen sogar landsleute und jetzt muss
joe biden bei den taliban die die feinde
der vereinigten staaten sind muss er um
eine fristverlängerung battle dass sie
wegen das bis zum 31
viele leute aus fliegen können das ist
das größte außenpolitische debakel
handwerklich in der geschichte der
vereinigten staaten seit ich mich
zurückerinnern kann das übertrifft
vietnam saigon den abzug das übertrifft
diese geiselnahme stellt euch vor wenn
die die zehntausenden von amerikanern
nicht rausbringen das sind tausende von
amerikanern nach geisa dann werden die
vereinigten staaten vom größten
bekämpfung der taliban zum größten
sponsor weil sie nämlich lösegeld
bezahlen müssen und die medien sind also
von einer blindheit geschlagen und das
ärgert mich weil man ist immer noch in
diesem tromp session drin dass man bei
nicht sicher ob die faz heute gelesen
also das ist mit samthandschuhen wenn
beiden wenn wenn trammplatz im weißen
haus sitzen würde dann hätten wir
lichterketten und den ganzen globus die
seine entfernung aus dem weißen haus er
erfordern würden also beiden ist ein
unglaublich unfähige präsident
tschuldigung ich sage das als jemand der
also sehr viel für die amerika üblich
gibt es widerspruch
das werden wir über ein jahr
ich würde erstmal ganz klar sagen ja es
stimmt ihr seid immer noch in die
hypnotisierende diesen beiden ruhig ich
war niemals für beiden ich war niemals
für beiden und ich bin auch er man kann
sie am auto ich bin eher bei den
republikanern als bei den demokraten von
mir selbst aus ich werde nicht wieder
entflammt darum geht es nicht es geht
hier nicht um meine persönliche
überzeugung mein herz ist nicht für joe
biden das hat noch nie gegen geschlagen
aber was ich sagen das ist ich stimme
dir zu damit das ist natürlich der abzug
falsch war auch mit drei ausrufezeichen
wir abgelaufen ist es ist natürlich ein
skandal aber klar wo wirklich oder durch
wird schon zwei mal zwischendurch schon
jetzt hört der
sendung heute und dabei bist du denn
wirklich dass die amerikaner ist ebenso
übernehmen werden nur drei punkte kurz
dann gebe ich hier aber glaubst es
wirklich weil punkt 1 die
flüchtlingskrise wird ja nicht dahin
kommen dass die demografisch so weit
entfernt das problem werden wir in
deutschland haben aber nicht die
amerikaner da ist schon mal der erste
punkt der zweite punkt ist wie viele
amerikaner waren überhaupt noch von dem
afghanistan-einsatz überzeugt das war
für mich der zweite punkt ich glaube die
amerikaner nehmen es ihm gar nicht so
übel und deswegen ist die presse nicht
hypnotisiert sollte nun keinen
terroranschlag passieren in der nächsten
zeit in amerika oder in vielen anderen
orten dieser welt glaube ich sogar die
amerikaner werden joe biden auf lange
sicht noch dazu biete ja kaum natürlich
aus rechtfertigen und man kann natürlich
auch sagen wenn ich eines morgens um
sechs oder fünf uhr in der frühe
aufstehen mein bett verlassen und meine
frau eine karte schicke okay das war's
ich bin dann mal weg der kompression
sein dass in 20 jahren sich diese frau
nicht mehr an mich erinnern kann aber es
bleibt trotzdem eine schändliche tat und
wenn sie als supermacht als
ordnungsmacht mit einem auch globalen
web der anspruch die die amerikaner dann
können sie ihre verbündeten nicht so
behandelt da können sie nicht einfach da
ihrem schicksal überlassen und joe biden
hat diesen entscheid getroffen gegen den
rat seiner berater und es stimmt auch
seine vorgänger wollten raus aus
afghanistan
es stimmt dass diese als ganzes diese
geschichte nicht so durchdacht war aber
alle hatten gemerkt vor ihm das wenn man
so abschied hinterlässt man ein desaster
und der kollateralschaden ist zu groß
wir haben schon 20 tote am flughafen
liegen schnell bewegen schwäbische
schnell in unsere schlussrunde ein
bleiben bei beiden eine schnelle runde
ganz schnelle an der show bayern-tor
beiden besser oder schlechter als donald
trump so kann ich noch ein zwei spieler
nationale hat besser oder schlechter als
deutschland beide ein desaster bislang
patricia ich finde die haltung von
beiden besser weil friedlicher und ich
weiß auch nicht wie man den abzug hätte
anders gestalten können wenn sie wenn
man weggeht geht man weg man kann die
karte hinterlassen man kann gar nicht
sagen sich auf französisch verabschieden
egal jeder abzug wäre ist ein problem
gewesen und ob die afghanen überhaupt
jemals die verbündeten der amerikaner
waren oder auch von uns deutschen das
bezweifle ich wir waren besatzungsmacht
sie
zornig danke für die steile these
vertritt der danke für die tolle
diskussion lena ganz ganz toll und ich
weiß nicht über
frauen in der bundesliga
[Musik]